I feel like I'm fair to everybody well
maybe not everybody Megan McCain is
opening up about the one regret she has
from the view when you're talking about
crooked Hillary really worked during the
election I was like crooked Hillary
I hate Hillary Clinton as everyone here
knows it's that comment referring to
then presidential candidate Hillary
Clinton as crooked Hillary on air that
Megan apparently wishes she could
unsaved the view co-host tells Elle
magazine quote I really regret saying
that she was friends with my dad it's
really not fair
I call her crooked Hillary I do when I'm
talking about Hillary Clinton
what do you call she went on to
apologize saying her remarks were
contributing to the polarization of this
country I really come on there every day
open-minded just trying to explain it
okay not a fun job but everybody hates I
know you're angry you're angry that
Trump's president like a lot of plumbing
about every single he knows doing
yelling at me is gonna fix the problem
the conservative talk show host also
revealed that it was her late father who
talked her into joining the shelves it
made me so inspired that the ideals that
my fatherís Posterous career are the
ideals of America